the skill and expertise at st. Thomas's
infectious diseases unit is being tested
again London's first case of coronavirus
rushed here and straight into isolation
the unidentified patient was infected in
China and diagnosed in the capital as
one coronavirus patient enters the unit
one has been given the all-clear Steve
Walsh was discharged earlier and is now
back at home and reunited with his
family he said in a statement I'm happy
to be home and feeling well I want to
give a big THANK YOU to the NHS who have
been great throughout and my thoughts
are with everyone around the world who
continues to be affected by the virus
it's good to be back with my family and
I would ask you please to respect our
privacy from this point on mr. walsh
caught the virus in singapore and as he
traveled to france and then home to
England he unwittingly infected 11
Britons professor Keith Willett the NHS
lead on coronavirus said I'm pleased to
say that following two negative tests
for coronavirus 24 hours apart
mr. Walsh has been discharged from guys
and st. Thomas's NHS Foundation Trust
having made a full recovery following
his treatment mr. Walsh's symptoms were
mild and he's no longer contagious and
poses no risk to the public Steve Walsh
was brought here to the infectious
diseases unit the last Thursday six days
later and he's back at home the
emergency is over for him but for the
rest of the country it goes on where mr.
Walsh lives there is still
understandable concern including here at
Worthing hospital where one health
worker was infected worrying I work at
the hospital so
you know it's one of those situations
where you knew that possibly it was
going to come to the hospital sometimes
being started in Brighton so it is
worrying but at the same time I think
that you say it's contained so I'm
coming to work as normal at the moment
local schools remain open but they're
allowing parents to decide if their
children attend I just decided to take
her out because they could have just
shut just go down and give it clean down
you know so I'm not taking any chance
the fears of an outbreak are not
restricted to Brighton to prisoners here
at 8 MP Bullingdon in Oxfordshire are
being tested for the virus one has been
named as mark John Rumble he was
transferred here from a jail in Thailand
two weeks ago Thai authorities confirmed
his identity and insist he was not
presenting with any symptoms when he was
put on the flight to Britain there were
real concerns that his virus would
strike other towns and cities it was
only a matter of time Ashish Joshi sky
news